I would like to ask all the actors here
I mean
for us movie lovers and I know I'm
speaking in the name of kind of
everybody in the room it's a delight to
go back into the world of a filmmaker
that that has a vision that is so
particular that has a vision that is so
defined a style that is so defined as
Wes Anderson it's already I don't know
the movies are all different they talk
about a different thing but
it feels familiar it's very comfortable
to find this this universe again what
I'm wondering is how is it for you
actors those who comebacks and those who
are newcomers into this world how is it
to to dive into the mind of Mercy
Anderson
should we start with you ladies Maya
Scarlett
how was it
um
it's intense it was intense
um no I I um
yeah it's funny because of course the
world is sort of there you're in you're
in it you know you your the whole
environment is created there it's not I
I mean this was my only experience so uh
working you know as a live actor and not
a and not a dog yes for with Wes but um
no no he they're very much create the
whole environment and it's a physical
tangible usable space
so it actually I think in a way is
almost like doing
it's kind of more like doing theater
because you have the whole tangible
space and it's not you know you don't
have the same it's not this familiar
process of you know being on a sound
stage and you know going back to your
trailer and all this down time and then
you know all that stuff that just eats
up the momentum
um you know which is just part of the
process there's not much you can do
about it somehow Wes has avoided that
um and so it feels very vibrant and um
very much like a you know like you're
like you're working on in theater it's
it's very fulfilling and and exciting
yeah Maya you wanna add something
I mean I think Scarlett said it so
beautifully the the lack of hierarchy
and The Ensemble that Wes creates on set
in combination with the level of writing
storytelling and and the beauty of the
space that you're inside of just makes
it
um such a pleasure and it feels like
there's no pressure on you because every
part of the world around you works so
smoothly between the people that you get
to act with and be surrounded by and
um and the words you get to say and so
you just kind of you the process and the
product are aligned so beautifully and
it feels
I don't know it's just one wonderful
um and at ease even though it feels like
it should be such a high pressure
environment because of how high the
stakes are
we're both really good answers
but but this is more difficult because
of the visual aspect of the film I mean
for uh for for I don't know the social
composition is very important for West
and does that make the work uh I don't
know more demanding more
difficult
right
it absolutely makes the the work very
challenging uh we have to we have to
focus on what we do to me it feels like
Wes Anderson is a a conductor of an
orchestra and all of us are players of
our particular instrument and we hyper
focus on our instrument and just present
it Without Really knowing exactly how
it's all going to piece together and he
conducts it a little less of Brian a
little more Scarlet at this moment or
whatever it's so he he makes the
adjustments as he goes and like the the
the the dialogue in in the film there's
a part where where Augie goes in and
talks to the director and says I I just
don't think I understand the play and
and he says uh it well you don't have to
you just keep telling the story and
that's I think in a nutshell what the
film meant to me is that we go through
life we don't know exactly what's going
to happen how long Our Lives will be who
will be in our lives how it'll all play
out we just have to keep telling the
story just keep moving forward and then
be a storyteller
good night everybody
I'm back Ryan come back Stephen you want
to add something about working with Wes
well Wes uh shares with the cast before
we start filming is I can share the this
moving storyboard which is the animatic
and Wes voices all the characters in
this moving storyboard and if you saw
that storyboard last night it would have
been like equally entertaining and
Brilliant release it was so amazing and
then what he's shooting is is exactly
what he visioned in the storyboard so we
know going on set exactly what Wes wants
and I don't know how you do it it's well
but I I will say that the this this uh
the thing you describe is nothing like
the movie because the movie is entirely
about what you guys are doing you're the
the the whole movie is the actors
playing these things and so mine kind of
shows my plan yes but everything is a
total everything is improvised in a way
the emotions and the expressions and the
feeling of it are all coming from the
cast
um that's true but how you voice
everybody's character so is it's if was
I would love to see it in the movie
theater no no we never would do that we
never
yeah it's at least the animatics Jeffrey
what can we see on the animatics
uh
well it really is a blueprint and I
think if you if and maybe I'm uh I'm
overstepping but I think
um in terms of my insight but it seems
to me that there is a very you know
there's a specificity obviously to Wes's
frame
and that can't be improvised on set you
can't just show up and say okay maybe if
we it has to be there has to be a
schematic that exists prior to that and
I think that the the cartoons as Wes uh
refers to them serves as that it really
is a blueprint and Scaffolding and
everything that allows him to be able to
facilitate the vision on set so I mean
everything he does is uh is super
interesting you know it it it you know
creates
uh for example the way that we all
gather together creates community and
all of these things but everything has a
purpose relative to the work
and uh and I think above all else what
he achieves uh through this process
because we work in one of the most
inefficient
um uh spaces that exists but what he
creates is efficiency and and and and
and just sinew and streamlines it in a
way that I love because you know because
he also serves great meals at the end of
the day and you just want to hit it and
get back to the wine you know so
um yeah Bravo yeah
how did you react when I was asked you
to
do you want to be a dancing cowboy
[Laughter]
um well anytime Wes asks you to do
something for me it's like there's a
there's only a couple of people who can
who have the power to make you believe
you can do things that you didn't know
you could do
um so for me one of them is Amy Mullins
obviously who to whom I'm married and
the other is West so when he calls and
says and you know could you do the song
live and I said well yes but I don't
play the industry I'm not a musician uh
then he just asks again could you do the
song Live though and I said yes yes I
can do that okay and so it's a journey
because every time
um we do something it's a brand new set
of skills it's a com and then getting to
work with I mean so George and Jarvis
Cocker and these wonderful musicians and
making this troop and getting to dance
with Maya I mean dream come true